[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to game
sports coverage of summer game fest play
days say the right name key three there
it is uh 2022 this is the last interview
of the show everything is is pretty much
pretty much over save the best for last
in terms of la but yes we have saved the
best for last time and i are joined by
harvey smith from arcane yeah thank you
for having me we're just out here we
showed the
very first look at red fall gameplay
team's hard at work uh back home uh but
i was happy to come out and show that
off and be part of the the whole
bethesda xbox uh game show yeah so how
long ago did you start working on red
four
um god it was pre pandemic
uh it was like
a thousand years yeah like
uh games are already hard
and this is our most ambitious game ever
at the beginning of this project ricardo
and i were like
you know we need to take a creative risk
i had been on eight years worth of
dishonored stuff
through all the you know dishonored one
knife of dunwall brigmore witches
dishonored two death of the outsider he
had been on eight years of stuff like
dishonored one
those dlcs were dishonored and then pray
and then moon crash
which i think he was like creative
director of and so we wanted to shake
things up a little bit and
you know
we're like can we take the arcane dna
all the things people love the layers of
narrative the game mechanics it could be
you know
overlapping interesting creative ways
surprising ways uh the the immersive
movement in the body and all that stuff
rpg level up so somewhere between a
shooter and an rpg can we apply that to
open world
can we let you play single player can we
let you play multiplayer and so we set
out to do that and then the pandemic
happened and it just like was like here
catch this this anvil you know
so how long has it been
you know i honestly i don't know
um
all i know is that you know we're trying
to final the game now for early next
year right how do you know as a team
like
where to take a risk on something or
where to be like now we maybe need to
pair that back or dial it down a little
bit
yeah it's interesting because that's
really like what you want production for
you know you have this whole team of
people that are project planners um
you know susan cath we worked with for
years now
uh on the dishonored one dlc
and pray
and then about halfway through this
project she moved into a business
director role
uh still around still working with us
but ben horn
and aaron carter
took over as the leads of production and
they've been amazing and so they're
ideally
you know their job is to time box things
like i know you want to do this thing
but you only have this much time you can
tell me that you want to make trade-offs
but you know and then our job is to you
know force them not to do that right
like our job is to like you know make
the game as great as it possibly can be
um
but uh yeah it's a constant struggle
basically and traditionally arcane has
been more design driven than anything
and i think that's still true
but it just helps
bringing sort of like
a mature attitude about production it
helps people not work overtime it helps
features not get cut um but it's still
chaos it's still
a crazy process where um you know you're
simultaneously trying to put
cooler and cooler deeper things into the
game while other people are saying no
that doesn't fit we have to lose
something what do you do and it's it's
organic all the way through right um
obviously you talked about it being a
big creative risk for you and
i imagine for a lot of people who are
seeing the game for the first time it's
going to be quite a shock to the system
knowing what arcane has done previously
like whether it's dishonored or prey or
whatever it may be death loop there's
can been a kind of like a a lineage that
is very easy to see and this feels quite
different from it so i think a lot of
people are probably going to be like
what are the arcane where the arcane
bits and how do you kind of speak to
those died you know arcane fans who are
looking for
the experience they know and love from
you in there
yes i mean so first of all i feel like
you just tried to get an immersive sim
uh pun over on me the shock to the
system um
but uh yeah that's a good question like
one of our you know all of our games
like venn diagram right none of them are
a perfect circle uh prey is probably the
most pure
immersive sim that arcane's ever done
um dishonored overlaps heavily with it
but has a stronger focus on stealth prey
more on physics
the themes of prey are all empathy
dishonored is like
abuse of power and wealth imbalance and
things like that
how people
act when they're in the worst possible
situation
um
death loop is something different it you
know it's done by the lyon team uh dinga
and sebastian maton those guys
and
you know it's brilliant i didn't work on
it
but it added multiplayer in this
brilliant way right so
none of our games
overlap perfectly none of them are
purist in any any way but they are
infused with the same creative values
right moon crash is a roguelike but
um it you know it still feels like an
arcane game and i feel that way about
red ball like
again every square foot of the game is
is like has history and has narrative uh
your movement through the world feels
very immersive as you slide and climb
and get into gun fights with people
your rpg progression it's not just about
guns it's also about your character's
powers and how you level up
you know and so
the way we conceive of a world a setting
and try to make it as possible as
possible
um
and
the character you know the setting is
actually a character in a way it's like
dun dunwall or talos or the city of red
ball and so i think those people are
going to be pleasantly surprised there's
a reason why we drove
so hard to keep the single player pure
when you play single player you don't
play with bots like
i'm a big left 4 dead fan but this game
is not like left 4 dead it does not have
you running around with four or three
you know other colorful characters
talking if you play solo you play alone
you pick your character layla jacob remy
defender whichever one and you play
through
and then if you if you want to add a
friend you can a lot of people i think
are gonna like you know play with a
roommate or a partner or something just
two-player uh but if you go up to four
it becomes more like a party um
but there's still a stealth component
the ai is still perception-based
sight and hearing
we still have like surprise kills
you know uh there's a lot of stuff that
you will allure books everywhere you
know lots of dynamic dialogue the
characters talk and based on context
based on what's going on in the world
they they say different things based on
which characters they're playing with
they say different things so it's uh
it's very much an arcane game uh well
going back to the stuff about like the
narrative and you mentioned themes and
um maybe abuse of power and that kind of
stuff what is the theme for redfall then
yeah so um ricardo bear
uh worked with our narrative team
internally uh evan narcisse worked on
the game we have a group of people
internally that work with ricardo
the writing was divided between all of
them
uh but we knew up front that what we
wanted was
uh certain thematic elements right like
vampires were metaphor like monsters are
a metaphor and our vampires kind of
represent like a tiny tiny percentage of
people like the .01 percent who have
everything and they have it by preying
on everyone else and just draining the
life out of everyone else as the world
burns down around us right
um
and so that's kind of where we started
the the people who
they were already vampires um you know
before before even becoming vampires at
some level they already lack humanity
lack empathy um for the people around
them they come in and they destroy
communities they hollowed them out from
the inside
and so
there are a lot of themes related to
those things there are a lot of themes
related to
community like we have this whole game
system called take back redfall where
you capture neighborhoods one at a time
and make them safer
by doing some uh safe house missions
finding a safe house doing some safe
house missions taking down an underboss
who's kind of a bootlicker to the
vampire gods and securing that
neighborhood
and your missions are launched out of
like bases that are effectively civic
centers like the first one is a fire
department right so
somewhere down there there's this
concept of like people neighbors need to
come together
we all live in this community
um
let's band together let's feed the
hungry let's let's help the vulnerable
and and let's fight back against these
predators and those themes are kind of
like they're subtle they're not it's not
in your face but that's i think that's
what
you know it's really not for me to say
it's really when the game comes out for
you to say actually but like that's
that's what i would take would like you
to take away from it
there are obviously been so many
interpretations of vampires and vampire
mythos
over the years across
every medium known to man so where were
you sort of and the team picking and
choosing from or is it like you wanted
to do okay no this is the arcane take on
vampires
yeah it's interesting i think any
twilight in there
yeah i signed a bunch of autographs
earlier for dishonored and prey fans uh
at the
uh bethesda xbox event and uh xbox
bethesda event i think i'm supposed to
say but um this is your event now
but there was a guy who literally said
do you think there'll be a twilight
tie-in i don't know if he was joking or
not
but we yeah we wanted to put our own
spin on vampires as
uh science-based psychic
uh leeches essentially on society
uh
narcissists and you know people that
don't don't have that human connection
with the people around them with their
neighborhood or whatever
and so some of it was just driven by
that some of it was driven by the
um
brilliant concept art
that uh patrick our lead concept artist
did and
our art director karen you know guided
him through that and
know so our vampires were a unique
creation of course but we did we do have
an orientation that we do with new team
members uh where they hire on and we
ricardo and i walk them through a
cultural orientation for arcane and then
we also do one for the game that we're
working on right now which is red ball
and
we do have this one slide where it's
like you know this is not sparkly
romantic vampires nothing wrong with
that but like that's not what this is
these vampires are not aspirational you
don't want to be them like in the ann
rice books it would kind of be cool to
be less that or something right um
but
this is not this this is they're
horrible right and so we have we have
the what they're not slide where they're
not particularly religious they're not
gothic or romantic um
you know
they're
people that have traded away their
humanity you know so
are there any like
obviously one of the most interesting
parts of it is like there's always these
figures of mystique in the world like
obvious ones the outsider and
you kind of get to know that character
and it almost becomes like a you develop
a sympathy with that character is it is
it i mean
is it a cut and dry thing where the
vampire is a vampire is evil or is it a
case of like maybe you'll you'll learn
something about them that perhaps is are
they sympathetic okay is a nuance to the
way they're depicted
um yeah i know the right answer to that
question but
there are sympathetic characters in the
world and there are characters that have
suffered that
um work with you um
narratively but our vampires are not
sympathetic they are just monsters you
know and they
they're intelligent monsters they speak
they're full of
uh personality
but uh
no they're not like
is he on the dark side or not you know
they're just like 100 percent yeah
that seems like a lovely place to end it
javi thank you so much for coming down
and talking to us i'm very excited to
see more of registration oh thank you so
much for having me and it was great to
show
the first look at red falls gameplay and
we are literally just at the moment
where my voice is failing
me too that's why we're secretly
wrapping it up um but for more on summer
game fest because obviously there are a
couple more streams throughout the week
make sure to stay tuned to gamespot